I caught a fish this big and now I'm
going to jail two fishermen have been
charged with crimes after a cheating
scandal at the Lake Erie walleye Trail
fishing tournament after the tournament
director opened the walleye caught by
Jake Runyon and Chase Kaminsky he
shouted we got Wings there we go as a
viral video shows the fishermen loaded
up their catch with over seven pounds of
lead weights enabling them to win the
tournament and the 28 thousand dollar
prize other fishermen became suspicious
of the pair after they dominated the
walleye fishing season all year long
running and Kaminsky were indicted on
charges of attempted Grand Theft a 4th
degree felony for trying to steal
property valued at over 7 500 they're
also charged with cheating possession of
criminal tools and unlawful ownership of
wild animals the pair allegedly stuffed
other fish with fish fillets which are
the basis for the wild animal charge now
the local prosecutors described the
conduct as not only dishonorable but
also criminal no word on whether the
Lake Erie walleye Trail fishing
tournament will ever recover from the
Scandal